nous passons une application plein de
bons conseils culinaires bonjour justin
l'application s'appelle à pettitte à
elle a été créé par un ingénieur agro
alimentaires originaires de bucca il
promeut bien évidemment la cuisine fait
maison
exactement alors est ce que vous êtes
déjà demandé en ouvrant votre frigo
qu'est ce que je vais manger ce soir
tous les jours et bien voilà il ya
l'application est fait pour vous c'est
un dépanneur à d'idées de recettes
elle en propose plus de 1000 tout testé
par ap sia est vue avec des chefs et des
diététiciens
on s'est rendu compte c'est que les gens
de cuisine lycée ne cuisinent et pas
assez parce qu'ils manquent et dj au
quotidien il manquait d'idées il
manquait de temps et donc du coup on
s'est vraiment concentré sur ce problème
le manque d'idées et du coup on a voulu
créer cette application qui est du coup
un algorithme de recommandations de
recettes qui prend en compte du coup
toutes les contraintes que des personnes
vont avoir et qui vont être
déterminantes dans leur nom leur envie
de cuisiner et comment ça fonctionne et
c'est simple c'est ça exactement vos
rides et c'est ça aussi c'est pratique
vous ouvrez l'application elle est
disponible sur apple et android
et là vous créez un compte il faut
répondre à quelques questions selon vos
envies notamment quels types de recettes
vous souhaitez est ce que c'est pour une
entrée un plat ou un dessert quel est
votre envie express convivial pour
combien de personnes vont cuisiner on
s'adapte à tout même à votre matériel et
à vos compétences est ce que vous savez
cuisine et du chou fleur ou encore
dépend des terres tu vas pas être été si
c'est moi qui sert à quoi ce
questionnaire et bien en fait c'est
parce que l'application cherche à
encourager les personnes à cuisiner au
quotidien avec une alimentation plus
saine et donc elle s'adresse aux
personnes qui aimeraient se lancer mais
qui ne savent pas comment faire et donc
le but c'est de ces questions c'est de
s'adapter d'accompagner ces personnes en
leur proposant des recettes sur mesure
avoir une recette scène c'est bien mais
si elle nous donne pas envie si on peut
pas la faire parce qu'on n'a pas de
course et peut pas la faire parce qu'on
a jamais cuisiné des épinards et qu'on
n'a pas du tout le temps d'apprendre la
technique etc
en fait on va pas la cuisine et donc ça
sert à rien en fait donc c'est vraiment
une application pour le sur mesure c'est
ça aide les personnes à passer à
l'action et du coup à savoir comment
mentalement et pouvoir le faire
réellement en fait dans leur cuisine
l'application est gratuite il y aura une
fonctionnalité nutrition qui va être
mise à jour vous pourrez faire attention
notamment à tout ce qui est allergies ou
encore cholestérol et puis cette
nouveauté donc sera accessible dans les
prochains jours via a par contre cette
fois un abonnement premium